là pour commencer j'aimerais faire
marcher un petit peu votre imagination
si je vous dis demain vous quittez votre
travail quitter votre appartement vous
quittez votre quotidien pour aller vivre
dans quatre cinq six mccann ça veut dire
pas compliquer
je comprends sa santé comme ça je vais
essayer de vous montrer sur la scène
bien pu représenter 4 5 mètres carrés
faire changer d'avis par quatre ou cinq
arrêts ça peut représenter à peu près ça
pas l'air d'en avoir trop convaincu
maintenant je vais vous montrer ses
photos
voilà ce que ça peut représenter de
manière plus vivable 4 5 ou 6 bat quatre
femmes déjà vous aebischer inrocks et
maintenant vous allez vous dire ma super
mais vivent dans ton 4 mai carré dans un
camion pour toi c'est ça l'évolution
bah oui en quelque sorte vous allez vite
comprendre pourquoi il ya deux ans
j'étais chargé marketing dans nos
petites pme à nantes
njock super sympa après cinq ans
d'études en université est en école de
commerce
schéma classique pendant de mettet
ingénieur dans une grosse voix que de
btp a nato ci après avoir fait cinq ans
d'études
alors si centrale à nantes mais aussi
votre tracé schéma classique on avait
les john gamme payer un grand
appartement à nantes du binôme une
terrasse pour accueillir les cobras ont
aidé tout ce dont on avait toujours rêvé
on a deux paires chats ont adopté un
chien dans quel but que le scénic
version familiale de tout y est et on
avait toujours on était là on avait
toujours rêvé d'être enfin la société
nos amis de famille avait toujours rêvé
qu'on soit dépensé mon salaire dont du
shopping en allant au restaurant en
sortant avec nos amis sans trop de
questions finalement et quand on est
enfant nam adolescents on est formaté
par l'éducation qu'on soit par nos
familles et même par l'école on nous
apprend à bien travailler à l'école pour
avoir un bon métier guitare mais c'est
quoi un bénitier committee c'est un
métier qui rapporte de l'argent
c'est un métier grâce auquel elles
meurent à un bon salaire pour un avoir
une belle maison pour se payer une belle
voiture
c'est ce qu'on ne s'apprennent d'avis
alors pour la plupart s'attelle à la
tâche et on essaye d'avoir des bonnes
notes
faire de longues études pour décrocher
finalement un cd à voir on savait la la
stabilité fameuse stabilité fois que
c'est d'ailleurs un autre les parents
adorent la stabilité en temps les
comprends qu'il ne rêve pas de du
meilleur pour son enfant stable serait
alors nous aussi on a joué au bon petit
soldat
et est ce si difficile de remettre tous
en question ses schémas de plus ces
principes de vie on a du mal à 6 à se
demander si nous aussi ça nous
correspond et est ce que tout ça nous
rend heureux et à partir du moment où il
a commencé à se poser ces questions là
on a tout remis en question la
nourriture qu'on mange ou vêtements
qu'on porte au logement dans lequel on
habite tout y est passé
on est devenu végétarien d'arrêter de
faire du shopping
on est revendu toutes nos affaires
services essentiels d'ailleurs
saint-exupéry viser la perfection des
patins n'ont pas notre qu'il n'y a plus
rien à ajouter mais lorsqu'il n'y a plus
rien à retirer
et en effet on s'est senti plus allégée
à pézilla alors on a profité du salon
ces fameuses projet payer pour partir en
vacances déconnecter un petit peu loin
la france il retourne ce fut un vrai
électrochoc
alors vous allez me dire oui le blues
post vacances on connaît tout ça ça
passe bien non pas là ça a duré duré
duré santé plus du tout en phase avec
notre quotidien sentais qu'il y avait un
nouveau virage à prendre un changement
majeur à effectuer dans vos vies alors
on a pris une décision radicale
on a quitté notre appartement on a
quitté notre travail on a vendu presque
toutes nos affaires et on est partis
voyager on avait besoin en fait de se
retrouver avec moi c'est à dire moins de
responsabilités et moins de stress
et surtout d'y trouver du plus juste
découvert plus de mouvements plus de vie
alors on est partis voyager en vannes
pendant six mois à quatre avec notre
chat et le chien on s'est retrouvé du
jour au lendemain comme quoi dans 80 des
cas rires non c'est juste de quitter un
quotidien confortable un appartement
confortable
on s'est retrouvé avec le strict minimum
et on s'est rendu compte que dans notre
quotidien on a cumulé vraiment beaucoup
trop de choses avant de partir on a
vraiment dû faire des choix pour pouvoir
sélectionner les jo les objets dont on
avait vraiment besoin
tout ce qu'on avait dans le van avait
une utilité temps il faut pas trop ne
faut pas être sorti du saisi pour 30
conte peut pas transposer ce qu'on a
dans 60 m² en cas de calme logique alors
voilà on a sélectionné les objets
vraiment utile et tout ce qu'on avait
dans le van était utile et remplit sa
fonction est remarquable plusieurs
longueurs et outre le fait de cette
délesté de tous ses biens matériels
c'est aussi des listes et
psychologiquement c'est à dire que on
n'avait plus la pression des factures du
loyer à payer des transports bons d
apprendre du matin lorsque tu es bien
effet rempli de découvertes de
mouvements de devises finalement et ce
style de vie nous a ramenés aux basiques
c'est à dire que tous les jours on avait
des questionnements on n'a pas du tout
dans un schéma de 8 à 6 c'est à dire que
on devait poser la question de où vont
aller dormir le soir où aller aux
toilettes où trouver de l'eau pour boire
à se toucher des questions complètement
différent d'un quotidien classique mais
pour remplir des besoins primaires et
ses questionnements
tous les jours pour vivre et à gaza
outre le fait d'avoir du coup si peu
d'espacé ce type d'objet on avait
également de ressources dépôt de gaz le
dos pour d'électricité et on devait
vraiment faire attention à toutes ses
ressources et les protéger au maximum et
ça nous a ouvert les yeux sur notre
consommation au quotidien dans un
appartement dans une maison classique
pour vous donner un exemple en vannes ou
consommer 20 litres d'eau par jour pour
2 personnes contre des biens station 147
litres d'eau par jour et par personne
dans un quotidien classique enfin de
cette fois c'est vraiment énorme
bouzard extrêmement sensibilisé à toute
cette surconsommation des ressources au
quotidien alors à l'heure où on voit
toujours plus gros tours grosse voiture
plus grosse maison un poste toujours
plus élevées à travers toujours plus
gros on a pris justement de ce
contrepied de voir toujours plus petit
un petit logement plus petit de plus
petites ressources du petit revenu et ça
m'a bien justement vous questionnez vous
sur votre propre consommation sur vos
possessions fait le bilan rapidement
dans votre tête de tout ce que vous
possédez de bataille également de votre
habitation de la taille de notre voiture
et je suis sûr qu'il y en a certains qui
doivent se dire c'est vrai que vrai
signé peut-être un petit peu noir rempli
peut-être que la taille de ma voiture ne
correspond pas vraiment à des besoins
mais surtout posez vous une seule
question est ce que tout ça vous rend
heureux
est-ce que posséder toutes ces choses
vous rendez vous or aujourd'hui on
possède dix ans consomment toujours plus
alors que le besoin eux n'augmentent pas
prenez l'habitation par exemple il est
pas rare aujourd'hui de voir une famille
de 3 ou 4 personnes habitait dans le
en 50 mais carrément maison un grand
jardin alors at-on vraiment besoin de
sable le fait-on parce que c'est l'un
des hommes
je m'interroge vraiment là-dessus alors
quand on se pose toutes ces questions
quand on fait tous ces constats on se
dit est ce qu'il serait peut-être pas
possible de dépenser moins d'argent et
du coup d'avoir moins besoin de
travailler l'idée serait peut-être donc
de travailler moins pour gagner moins et
dépenser moins dans les choses peut-être
un peu inutile qui prennent du temps et
de l'argent à entretenir mais qui
prennent aussi du temps et d'argent
apprendre à produire qui polluent et qui
font du mal à la planète
parce qu'à l'heure où les autres
scolaires n'ont plus beaucoup de temps
qu'il lui faudrait sa muse il est
peut-être temps aussi de prendre tous
ces critères la reconsidération biens de
consommation et tout ça c'est également
du temps dépensée et en éthique pas le
bien le plus précieux n'en plus savoir
ce qu'ils on peut avoir un petit
glossaire beaucoup plus d'argent une
trop grande maison grosse voiture mais
le temps lui on ne peut pas l'acheter
dans citant quotas qui nous est donné il
n'y a pas de robe suppléments et c'est
ce qui nous a convaincus dans ce style
de vie c'est d'avoir la un rapport au
temps complètement transformé qui nous
est propre et pour nous à part le temps
c'est être libre
finalement être libre d'aller où l'on
veut est donc d'organiser une journée
comme on l'entend c'est le vrai prix de
la liberté alors l'évolution pour nous
ce n'est pas la barre plus gros salaires
plus grosse maison grosses voitures
n'ont vraiment pas pour nous l'évolution
c'est plutôt de réduire tout ça c'est de
réduire nos déchets la taille de nos
habitations
redevient toutes ces pollutions ces gaz
à effet de serre évolué pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est travailler moins
dépenser moins mais vivre nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]